il y a deux ans je parle sous le
contrôle de maître le terrier on est des
docks le 17 mars 2020 1 logiquement et
qu'est ce qui se passe et 17 mars 2020
on était comprise et ben oui c'était le
début de tout ça souvenez vous ces
images chocs de tout ce qu'on a vécu qui
était invraisemblable
ce compliment qui avait duré près de
deux mois des rues complètement vide ou
quoi on a vu plus vite que ça c'était
tout à fait étonnant il faisait beau on
s'en souvient si vous souhaitez
sensibiliser à vos souhaits agathe si
vous souhaitez sensibiliser vos ados les
plus jeunes je vous conseille à vos
amours agathe
chez
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron alors
attention pas le président fournit des
programmes en cours d'une conférence de
presse concise rapide efficace duré
quatre heures 09 a sorti quatre ans et
demi voir ça les journalistes au début
de la course que je considère que les
voici à la fonctionnement satisfaisant
je considère qu'aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être pas une question qui
vous a traversé l'esprit vue et son âge
mais vous faites quoi si vous perdez
vous avez été banquier d'un vice
président de la république que fera quoi
le prochain emmanuel macron si vous
n'êtes pas réélu
est ce que vous pourriez arrêter la
politique merci
[Musique]
écoutez
c'est pas une coquetterie de vous dire
que je me suis pas vraiment intimement
poser la question attention il faut pas
vendre l'eau à l'ours avant de leur
quota compris quoi non on n'a pas
compris et essayer encore on pas vendre
l'ours avant la peau voilà c'est mon
dernier mot
[Musique]
sa soif
ce tir est au numéro de téléphone
cellulaire afin d'échanger de vanier un
pistolet
[Musique]
hockey
georges best a été un des plus grands
joueurs de foot à la fin des années 60
est alors il a une phrase qui est
devenue culte parce qu'évidemment il
était très très riche et il a dit voilà
j'ai dépensé tout mon fric en fille est
en belle bagnole et le reste je les
gaspiller
ses extraordinaires et peut-être
pourrions-nous dire le projet de
juste entré dans la semaine
attention ne vide pas la première
mi-temps
galéjade
c'est la semaine de la langue française
et de la francophonie mais n'en faites
pas trop quand même vous avez été
condamné mais toute la france non mais
moi aussi et vous aussi vous avez été
condamné peut-être des ventes pour
atteinte aux intérêts en effet devant
tout le monde le lui ben moi aussi
j'avais fait neuf ans que la télévision
mois et peut-être vous serez condamné
mais violences sexistes ou sexuelles
vous serez condamné
la blache objet du sol et mercier c'est
très violent merci à vous écouter la
sauvegarde ou non il est 2e balle de la
pologne monsieur jadot on parle de la
soirée je vous attaque en diffamation
mais n'hésitez pas à monsieur lebon
folli follie mauvaise décision je ne
suis pas un donneur de sont chute anti
patrick cohen voilà qui est un donneur
de leçon je l'aimé encore ce matin
donner des leçons sur mon émission ils
savent les gens ne veulent plus de ça
voilà on est quand même à patrick cohen
il est très gentil mais il est chez de
billes un il est tranquille dans son
petit appartement du 6e arrondissement
je sais pas où il habite mais bon voilà
on y va tous les soirs poser son cul sur
la chaise de c'est à vous un pour dire
2000 pour prendre un salaire mon qui
doit être assez confortable et se permet
de donner des notions conseillez moi il
m'avait déjà alpaguer un jour sur un
sujet et c'est vrai que il chance oui je
rends compte deux jours après dans la
rue a forcément je vais le voir
bonjour avec délicatesse
et joël mois et bigoudis mais j'adore ce
que tu fais non les courageux du coup
bah oui mais voilà c'est comme ça quand
même derrière lui reparti donc j'espère
que les jeunes se battent pour la
planète pour le commerce équitable que
la cause animale c'est quelque chose
c'est pas mal pas en train de miauler
devant l'aisance polaire et la fonte des
glaces qui vous échappe un peu mais rien
ne me choque
rien ne m'échappe je connais
l'enthousiaste la générosité et de la
jeunesse partout et de la jeunesse
française en particulier louis viala pts
en haute-loire mais il travaille dans
une brasserie d'yssingeaux à 15 km de là
avec un salaire de 1200 euros nets la
facture carburant plomb de son budget en
ce moment alors lundi dernier ce
passionné d'équitation a décidé de
laisser sa clio au garage et il nous
raconte la suite de que l'on cheval je
suis au travail à cheval je me battrai
pour leur transmettent la france que
nous ont transmises nos parents
pas leur transmettre un liban en grand
parce que c'est ça leur avenir si on ne
fait rien et si je ne suis pas élu
président d'adams
le liban
avait beaucoup de libanais me disent que
j'ai un laïc comme moi j'ai deux
libanais en france nous disposons il
n'arriva pas le sujet ça y est c'est
pour s'habiller n'ouvrira le sujet
[Musique]
un meeting est perturbée par l'intrusion
d'un homme mais il en fallait plus pour
troubler valérie pécresse qui ne s'est
pas démonté grâce à ses talents
d'actrice et qui en payent le prix
parfois du sacrifice ultime
[Applaudissements]
là tout à faire du mal à ces surnoms non
alors une histoire très complet d'études
fait du mannequinat 3 comme ça ça nous
déçoit à côté et finalement je me
retrouve à faire ça tu vois alors
qu'elle est à pékin express en
ouzbékistan dans un bye tarik et sa voix
là tu vois franchement elle est belle ta
vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la tyrolienne et ses sensations fortes
une expérience inoubliable à 30 km/heure
au costa rica pour ce jeune garçon
surtout quand une surprise de taille se
présentent sur le parcours
[Musique]
une rencontre improbable avec un
paresseux heureusement le petit
aventurier qui fonçait à toute vitesse a
pu freiner à temps pour ne pas blesser
l'animal appelé aussi scientifiquement
haye
papy renverse la table de stéphane mais
on y est arrivé hier par le mental et
parle son mental on y est arrivé le jeu